this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm christy wright and joining me
today is new york times best-selling
author and my good friend in real life
rachel cruz and we are here for you
we're taking your calls triple eight
eight two five
five two two five so if you have got a
call about money
if you've got a call about work uh
career change starting a business side
business small business y'all know i
love to talk about that if you've got a
question about relationships how to
spend your time it's been a real kick
i've been on lately with a new book that
i put out take back your time regardless
of what it is we are here for you we'd
love to talk we'd love to hear your
story hear your question maybe give you
some advice or maybe just be a sounding
board to help you process what the best
move is for you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five rachel i love when i get to host
with you because this is one of those
things that we you know we were talking
even off air we are friends on real life
but we also get to work together have
our desks side by side and host the
ramsay show so this is going to be fun
do all this together i know i love it i
love it so great so so great and it's
friday y'all it's the weekend you got
you got fun plans everybody's in a good
mood on friday so beautiful weather here
in nashville
we are uh excited to hang out with you
give us a call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we're gonna kick off this hour by
going to indianapolis indiana with
rebecca hey rebecca how are you
hello great how are y'all great what's
going on
excellent um yes um my husband and i we
are on baby step six with two thousand
dollars left to pay off the mortgage wow
and
yes we're pretty excited thank you and
technically i guess now we're probably
not on six anymore but i refuse to think
that um hubby had a medical emergency
this year so we now have six thousand
dollars left to pay on the medical bill
so the dilemma that i'm having is
typically of course we would just pay it
off with the money we have on hand but
since i have an hsa
i'm trying to figure out if it's
actually better for us to
go through and max the hsal this year
and next year so we can use the
the tax-free dollars instead of using
the emergency fund that we have on hand
of what it is
how much do you guys have in your
emergency fund
um
so we've got so we definitely have six
what we consider six months worth and
then we also have
and we actually have another fund that
we have enough in there because we had a
large appliance sinking fund so we have
money in there as well and how much do
you guys make a year
um
just this past year we got raises so the
two of us were right under 80. right
under 80. okay
honestly rebecca
if i were in your shoes i would at that
hsa because you guys are are to the
point that you're still you're investing
you have no debt you have an emergency
fund and you can use that hsa actually
as an investment vehicle
and actually be able to max it out but
it but what it ends up doing is it rolls
into basically an investments that you
can keep so the fact that you can cash
flow
this medical bill at six six thousand
dollars right is that what you said yes
okay if it was sixty thousand dollars we
may have a different discussion but i
mean i think you guys have this in your
six month emergency fund write the check
and just pay it off pay the medical bill
off and then
uh yeah keep those hcc dollars in there
and to be able to use that as an
investment instead of instead of using
it actually for
specific medical purposes does that make
sense
wow okay yeah and and i mean that was my
immediate reaction but then as i started
thinking and thinking about the fact
that it's tax-free dollars i'm like okay
is it advantageous to actually go
through it the next few months to do
that or do we just pay it and say we're
done no i hear you totally and again i
think if your income was different if
the medical bills were a different
amount all of that may have changed that
answer but honestly it's six grand
and i would do that and man you're gonna
have your house paid off here in just
like probably two three months i mean
you guys are gonna be an incredible spot
so i if i were you i would just i'd use
the emergency funds um or the money that
you have in that syncing fund i think
either one's great and write the check
and pay it off yeah and i think one of
the things that's so interesting too is
you're in such a great position rebecca
to be able to do that you've worked so
hard to get to baby step six so this is
a small setback it may feel like it but
um you're in a great position to pay it
rachel for for anyone listening right
now that's going what is she talking
about hsa as an investment will you just
explain that really briefly because i
think a lot of people may not know
what you were just describing yeah so in
health savings account obviously you
have you can have cash in there to use
for medical purposes but if you don't
touch it and don't actually use it for
medical purposes it ends up
basically flowing into an investment
yeah growing tax free yes vehicle and so
if you work with one of our smart
investor pros you can use that when
that's what winston and i do so we'll
pay medical because we're on baby step
seven we'll pay medical just out of
pocket um i mean obviously we have
insurance and all of that but we don't
use our we have an hsa but we use it
more for investment purposes at this
point um and again that's what i would
recommend for rebecca because she's at
that point but not everyone is you know
if you're if you if you have an hsa and
you need it for medical purposes and
you're on baby steps one two three uh
then that's great yeah use it it's what
it's there for right um but if you don't
have to touch it then it's another great
option for an investment well i think
that's good to remind people of because
it's called a health savings account the
assumption and i thought this for years
was that it could only be used for that
right and i just love that reminder
especially for those people that are in
baby step four or after that it can be
used differently and so if you don't
have a smart vester pro if you don't
have an investment professional in your
corner they can help break that down for
you even further and explain why uh but
this is the goal y'all is to build
wealth and that's one more way that you
do it so i love that i love that example
all right let's go to fort lauderdale
florida with christian hey christian how
are you
good how are you guys doing great what's
going on
uh well i'm 21 years old i make about
5500 a month and uh i still live with my
mom i was wondering if i'm in baby step
3b i was wondering if you guys think i
should start investing in a roth ira or
if i should buy a house or go rent
somewhere
well you're doing great what do you do
for a living um i work on i work in the
marine industry i i'm like i work on
yachts cool awesome yeah well how much
do you have saved so far
i have about fifty thousand dollars
saved
okay specifically for your down payment
um that's what i had it set aside for
yeah was to buy a house yeah but um you
know i'm turning 22 soon
and i still live at home and i think
it's probably about time that i get out
but i also
you know with the way the market is
right now everything's just crazy
expensive my goal is to buy it this year
and then everything's spiked up yep
absolutely
um so christian i mean i i don't think
there's a right or wrong here and chris
you can chime in if you if you disagree
or agree but you know
a little bit of me says yeah i mean if
you have the money
and if you know you're going to be in
this area for longer than five years and
real estate is something that's kind of
that next step of yeah we're gonna i'm
gonna invest in it and i'm gonna be here
and then and then you start your baby
step four after you buy the house i mean
that is all possible yes and i think
that the market obviously is higher now
and you know what you're getting
yourself into
but also you're 21 and you may say yeah
i may be in fort lauderdale now i may
not be in 12 months i don't know if you
still feel like you're in a transitional
season i would rent rent for another
year or two it's not going to kill you
just to be a little safe but if you know
your roots are planted there and you
have the cash
for a 10 to 20 down payment and that's
what you want to do i think investing
real estate is great yeah i think you
consider some of those variables because
you if you do decide to rent there's no
shame in that you may learn something
about yourself living on your own what
you want in a home just by renting for
six months or a year um yeah you could
go either way i could see benefits
either way but you've got you've got
yourself in a good spot christian well
done great job this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org
budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
i'm christy wright joined today by my
good friend fellow ramsay personality
rachel crews and we are taking your
calls triple eight eight two five five
two two five if you have a question
about money business time management or
really anything you wanna talk about we
are here for you at the ramsay show it's
fun friday and we're excited to talk to
you so we're going to go to atlanta
georgia with curtis hey curtis how are
you
hi there good how are you great what's
going on
so uh i'm currently a retail manager i
haven't been in it for very long
and i have a master's in a bachelor's
degree in
music performance
there's not a lot of growth or payment
increase opportunities at my current job
and i'm unsure what a career path i can
pursue with the experience i've acquired
with my degrees um i'm looking for some
a career advice
well let's let's back up a little bit i
wish um ken coleman was on the show
today he could he could jump in and we
could phone a friend help him out he has
an amazing um path he walks people
through on getting clear but i mean i've
learned a ton from him and i know a bit
myself about just you know following
your your passions let's back up a
little bit what did you want to do
originally when you pursued this music
um originally i wanted to be a professor
uh at a college for music um
and i learned very quickly there's maybe
four jobs a year with 500 people going
for the same job so
then i wanted to be just a private uh
lessons teacher
which i was doing and then when covid
happened i went from maybe 30 students
to five um
and
it was very very evident that it's very
unstable until i teach on the side but i
don't rely on that money anymore um
does that make sense well i totally get
what happened during covet my question
is
um and you're you're right about things
being different last year but let me ask
you this why have you not built it back
up why have you not like poured fuel on
that fire you know you can do it you
don't depend on it and i get that i get
that but i mean going all in to build it
back up to 30 students to to make this a
substantial business why have you not
done that
um
i mean i think that's a great question
and i think it might just be the fear of
failure yeah um it might be a very
evident thing but also
um
i realized that i wanted to take the
financial obligation off of my passion
because i felt as i was relying on it to
pay my bills i wasn't enjoying it
anymore
so
yeah if that makes sense it does i'm
curious is would you say that's true all
the time or just during the year of
when it's not stable meaning
uh let's go back to the peak of it when
you've got 30 students you're serving
them you're adding value oh by the way
you get a paycheck you're getting paid
to do the thing you love to do
was that an issue then or was it only
when covet hit and you started getting
desperate and scared when your students
were dropping off
yeah so uh in reflection
um i would see
myself like getting up into the lessons
each day kind of dreading it
and
i had 30 students but i didn't teach all
30 every month there was always people
dropping out and
the first thing to go is back to fun
lessons
when people are financially struggling
um
and
and so the uh
i wasn't have i didn't have my ideal
client if that makes sense my students
were whoever i could get
where now the students i do teach
are excited and into it
um and i wouldn't turn away students as
long as they were
my ideal client going now if that makes
sense so if you could do that is that
what you would want to do like if you
could build this business up
hypothetically if you could build it up
you could have a full schedule you're
earning good money you're having fun
you've got your ideal student if you
could do that again would you want to
um i i think so um
but to to be honest i feel like i've
lost all that passion like i've even
contemplated
you know selling my my saxophone because
i haven't touched it in over a year
um
and common thread throughout the music
industry like in terms of the academic
side of things
this lack of passion so i i'm not sure
if it's
something i need to continue doing on
the side with more stable like nine to
five jobs or if it's something i can
pursue i just am not hopeful that it
would
lend itself profitable to like my
savings goals and
uh
to help me get through all the baby
steps yeah
you know curtis i want to tell you
something that i think could be at play
here and you can correct me if i'm wrong
i may be off base here but i've had
several calls like this and they all are
from people that ran a business a small
business or side business
in the pandemic
and because of the pandemic they lost
their clients and they had to close
and while things are open back up and we
don't have the restrictions we had back
then and they could start it again they
don't and i don't think it's because
they can't because the world is not
there the clients are not there i think
it's because they've been wounded and
curtis when when we have a side business
or small business it's personal it's
your heart it's you it's your service
it's your it's your passion
it's your gifts that you're putting out
there and then even though it's a
worldwide pandemic that caused that
to slow down and stop it still feels
personal and it feels wounding
and all of us
whenever we've been wounded we have a
fight or flight response and we want to
tuck our tail and go home and go that
didn't work i guess i wasn't cut out for
that i i don't i can't do that anymore
and i just curtis i just want to be a
person that says if you want to do this
again
you can
i think if you got back into it you
would find that passion i think if you
could dust yourself off off from the
heartbreak you experienced last year
which was absolutely no fault of yours
i'd like to add yeah
if you could dust yourself off and you
could get back into it i think you might
love it again i'm not saying that's the
only path for you i'm gonna actually
have you um
stay on the line and have jenna send you
a copy of my book business boutique
which is a plan to start your business
if you want to look at that again
and send you a copy of ken coleman's new
book from paycheck to purpose which is
coming out in just a few weeks and
that's going to give you a very clear
path for pursuing your next stage in
your career if you decide to go that
route you'll have both options at your
fingertips that hopefully will give you
some
a path for clarity whichever route you
decide to go
i just i just want to encourage you to
consider the possibility that there is
still that fire in you you've just been
hurt you've been hurt like a lot of
business owners and uh we want to tuck
our tail and go home but i think those
students are still out there that need
you your target market students yeah
that need what you have to offer
absolutely and and i think that there is
and i think that you make a great point
because it's almost like this feeling of
rejection
and someone says oh i can't
but you take it because it's your
gifting yeah your passion and some basis
says no to you again no fault of your
own i mean the world shut down all of it
but when you hear that
25 times yeah it does something to your
spirit it does and so um and so curtis i
do i would i would i hope what christie
said just spoke life into you
that if this is in your future that this
does kind of give you this boost to say
okay you know what i'm i do i want to
try again because i do love it
and it is something that i was i was
really good at and i think i could do it
again but also give you the freedom too
curtis that hey maybe even though you
have a music degree and music has been
part of your life
maybe there's something totally
different you want to do and that's the
other aspect we're seeing so much now in
2021 is the amount of turnover that's
going on all over the country and ken
talks about this that people are now are
like okay if i'm going to jump into
something new
now's the time because it feels like
everything is shifting
industries that you know we're all the
way down on the ground are kind of
coming back up again or other ones have
been created i mean there's just this
whole other it feels like this whole new
world out there and so to give you
permission to curtis like christy said
that hey
maybe you kind of
realized okay maybe that's the end maybe
that was a season of my life and now
there's something
totally different maybe not even in the
music space that i want to pursue and
another thing that you love and you're
making money doing that too so i think
you have a lot of options curtis for
sure and
um
and it is hard you know and i don't know
where you are financially you said you
know for starting the baby steps and so
um depending on your debt level your
income your bills i mean all of that
yeah there is math and finances that
come into play that is a reality and so
to kind of map that out and say hey
maybe for two years i put the music
stuff aside and i just bust my butt
doing something and get myself in a firm
foundation financially then maybe even
the stress comes off and you're able to
dream more going back into that music
you know what i mean like yeah that's
the beautiful thing about life we get
choices you get to create this life and
create a life that you love curtis and
what you get to decide yeah and i think
too if you do spend some time reflecting
on the business route or a different
career route like we're talking about if
you choose the career route you will
know you chose that because it's right
not because you're running from some
type of rejection of the business so i
want you to revisit it even if it's just
to give you confidence that the career
route is the right one we're not going
to run from this rejection we're going
to consider it and then make the best
choice depending on what's right for you
i think you can do either and i think
you're in a good spot and hopefully
those two books will give you some
clarity about your direction thanks for
calling
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
well
if you are like most people you feel
like you never have enough time to stick
with your goals you set goals in january
they are gone by march and by the end of
the year you're wondering where those
goals went all together
y'all i gotta tell you one of my
favorite tools to help you stick with
your goals all year long is my goal
planner and our new
2022 goal planner is here it is
available
you need to sit right here
yes i'm going to take people on youtube
open up the unboxing yes
stop it
stop it it's beautiful here's the thing
and i don't just say this as a marketing
line they literally sell out rachel they
sell out they do they really and you
really do you guys message me and
because it's dated no we don't order
more we estimate the best that we can
the order for the year
typically they sell out at the beginning
of january
last year they sold out in the beginning
of december so if you're thinking about
getting this for a gift for someone go
ahead and get it shipping has been weird
across the country go ahead and get it
so you have it there's nothing weird
it'll make it by christmas and then you
don't have to worry about them selling
out this is where you put your plans on
paper on purpose i give you guys
inspirational content every single month
focusing on different areas of your life
of your life you've got journal
questions for reflection templates to
help you put this stuff into practice
and of course you've got your monthly
calendar your weekly calendar your to-do
list and there's even areas for you to
write down how you're taking care of
yourself your family what you're
grateful for it's very intentional like
everything we put out
get your 2022 gold planner today at
ramseysolutions.com
i promise you they do sell out if you
want one go ahead and get it i mean
these so you don't miss tabs so tabs the
tabs
per month so beautiful it really is
beautiful
it's amazing it's beautiful it's amazing
and there's so
much in here christy you know what's
cool too so good this is worth pointing
out because this actually relates to one
of the values that i teach even if you
set a goal in january things may change
in your life i talk about this in my
book take back your time so there's
opportunities every single quarter
there's opportunities three times that
year for you to check in and see if
those goals are still right for you so
maybe in april you go hey are those
goals right yes i'm going to stick with
them get re-motivated or maybe they need
to change and so it's incredibly
intentional it's a great tool for you to
not just manage your time but actually
stick with your goals so get your 2022
goal planner at ramseysolutions.com
rachel cruz and i are here for you on
fun friday taking your calls answering
your questions it's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five and we're gonna go to
philadelphia pennsylvania with phil hey
phil how are you
hi good afternoon thanks so much for
having me sure what's going on
so i'm uh i'm projecting to deploy next
year with the army national guard
and uh
as a result of this deployment i'm going
to be having a pay cut and approximately
thirty thousand dollars and i'm on baby
step two so my my feeling is that i
should
store some money away for that time for
my family while i'm gone just so there's
not a
drastic change in income for them
uh but i just wanted to hear what you
guys had to say please
yeah what do you do now
i'm a therapist a mental health
therapist
cool awesome well phil thanks for your
service and doing that um
i have a good friend and her brother has
been out for five months now out
in the middle east and it's just it's uh
you guys you guys um and your families
do a lot so um we want to thank you so
much for for your service
um so you guys are on baby step two and
you're gonna be cut and your your income
will go down 30 000 so how much
when you are deployed will you be making
i'm projecting 85 000. um
given
it's tax-free plus bah plus my pay grade
yes okay
and how much debt do you guys have left
so we have just south of uh 40 000 and
that debt is only uh before we started
financial peace we purchased a shore
house
and that's what's left on that mortgage
oh okay so so no other consumer debt
it's just the mortgage for the second
house is that 40 000
yes okay that's great uh well you guys
are in you know i mean i know the 40 000
obviously is is a chunk but but it's not
like it's
tons of car payments and credit cards
and all this you know
overwhelming i feel like that can be um
when there's multiple types of debt and
all that you guys have really made
progress and um that this is it so
yeah i mean i
i think that there's a level of comfort
considering that you're going to be gone
um for your family to have a little bit
more cushion than just that baby step
one and so i'm i'm great if you guys
want to save up a little bit of kind of
a smaller emergency fund
just for that but also with 85 000 um
i'm encouraged by that number because i
think you guys can still be chipping
away at this 40 000 even though
you are overseas and uh we've had just
so many
and it's pretty remarkable but so many
military
families that will come in and do their
debt-free scream and they'll talk about
that they were deployed you know even
when they paid off the debt or
you know they were working it while
their spouse was deployed you know like
that that's a part of their story and so
seeing that and hearing that i know it's
possible for you guys to still continue
on that baby step too
um and so it may give you all just a
little bit of peace of mind again
because it's a very uh volatile
situation when you're deployed i know um
or i could only imagine i should say
to have a little bit more of savings and
i'm comfortable with you guys doing that
but i still want uh that intention and
that intensity towards that 40 grand
because uh you can still be chipping
away while you're still deployed when
did you say you're um going to be
deployed
so it'll be next year uh ballpark is uh
fall so i have about a year oh about 12
months okay on on the track you're on
right now if you didn't set aside any
extra for savings for what you're
talking about when could you have that
40 paid off
i'll tell you my my wife is incredibly
disciplined uh she's such a amazing
person and we have three little girls
and over the last we did fpu in uh march
and so we've paid uh fifty thousand
dollars in debt since wow
okay i feel like you're going to get
this knocked out before you're gone phil
do you
i i agree um but my wife understandably
this is our second deployment together
yeah understandably um she's she's
feeling it uh even though it's a year
out and uh i just i want to make her
uh feel as comfortable as possible yeah
well i think one of the things that you
could do is you can just continue to
await this debt even if you want to save
it up save it up and then once you have
the 40 just put it on that get it
knocked out and then you could save a
little extra i think you're going to get
this knocked out and have some extra
savings for her by the intensity that
you guys have already shown and i can't
even imagine the amount of um peace
that's going to give her going into you
being gone you don't have that payment
and you've got a little extra cushion
you guys have done an awesome job you
can tell your gazelle intense and you're
on the same page and gosh it's just
awesome of how you're looking out for
her and considering her for her feeling
good stable secure while you're gone so
well done yeah six months i mean to your
point christy and i and i i'm glad you
asked that because i was thinking it's
coming up like here in the next month or
two but i'm like you know in six seven
months you guys paid off fifty thousand
dollars already yeah
so i i'm on board i think that you guys
can knock it out and have the money
saved um but that's awesome absolutely
incredible it's gonna give you that
peace of mind too because you're just
not you're not gonna have that payment
hanging over your head oh yeah and then
and then anything else your emergency
fund or extra savings or cushioning like
we're talking about is just bonus on top
of that and so i think that anytime
you're going through a major life change
and we talk to you guys about this
whether you are expecting a baby or um
something's going on you know maybe a
health crisis something major
yes that should be considered
in your your baby steps but often
sometimes just the fear of the unknown
makes us feel like we need to totally
change course and we don't because in
your case phil i think that the plan
that you're on is the right that's right
it's the right timeline there's not
going to be any major turns it's it's
interesting it's not um
it's not difficult circumstances i think
that overwhelm people it's just the
unknown it's just the unknown
uh you think somebody used this example
for me one time but you think about it
you come up on traffic
and if you've got somewhere to be that
can make you feel anxious because how
long are you am i gonna be in traffic i
don't know but if you come up on traffic
and there's a sign a construction the
sign that says traffic estimated wait
time seven minutes
your fear goes down your anxiety goes
down cause you go okay seven minutes
yeah i know exactly how long i can
expect to be here and so when you're
going through a life change it can feel
like that scary unknown but often you
don't have to change courses you don't
even have to change the pace in your
timeline sometimes it's just seeing on
paper how it's going to continue to work
and knowing hey i've just got to stay
the course i can still do this yep
staying consistent i think that's good
and that and i think that's great i
think the knowledge piece of that
unknown gives you that so whatever you
can do to get that logical knowledge
switch turned on helps that emotional
kind of erratic fear that can play in
yeah that's a great point that's why we
tell you guys to put it on paper when
you can see it on paper on a budget on a
plan when you can see it you can do it
it gives you that sense of control
and peace thanks for calling and thanks
again for your service phil
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm christy wright rachel cruz and i are
taking your calls triple eight eight two
five five two two five we're gonna go to
phoenix arizona with kirsten hey kirsten
how are you
hi i'm are you good how can rachel and i
help today
um
well i hope you can i am calling because
i need some advice on how to get
financially free from
some of the mistakes that i have made
i'm a single mom i lost my job and my
whole daughter
i lost my home daughter through a fire
and i moved to phoenix arizona i
currently have a new job i'm making
about 17 25 an hour
and um i'm in about a hundred thousand
dollars in debt with student loans card
notes um
credit card bills and things like that
and i'm just wondering what i should do
at this point um i thought about selling
my car
i was offered ten thousand dollars on it
and
i owe about 13 13 000 on it
um so i'm just trying to find out what i
should do to help eliminate this that
i'm really drowning right now and i i
don't know what to do yeah kristin i'm
so sorry
i'm so sorry
i can
i can um yeah hear it in your voice and
and obviously your story it's um
it's really difficult and being a mom uh
how is do you have do you have one child
yeah just one she's mine
yeah how old is she
nine she's nine okay that's so great
um
kristen i want
well i'll say that's what what i find a
lot of the times when
we talk to people with really difficult
situations which i feel like we do a lot
here at ramsey solutions
there is a loss of hope that people have
and i feel like that's a common thread
that we hear
when people really feel like life has
just kicked them and kicked them and
kicked them
and they're down and they just think i
don't even i don't even know
where to start i don't know what to do
um
so i just first want to encourage you
that there is hope
that even though it feels hopeless and
it feels like this is going to be a
never-ending part of your story this is
going to end
this this debt this exhaustion
this financial instability it is going
to end kristin
because you know what
you have the ability to end it
you have the ability to start making
choices and decisions and we'll talk
about that here in a second um
to be able to have hope that your
situation is is
is going to look different
so i want you to hear that from from
christie and myself that we've heard
um lots of situations and some very
similar to yours and
the beautiful thing is is that we
are able to make different choices day
in and day out to put us in a different
position so i want you to i want you to
you probably don't feel it now you may
not today but i want you to start
telling yourself
that you're gonna be okay
you don't feel like you're gonna be okay
right now because it's a scary situation
but i just want you to know there's hope
okay okay kirsten you
what you've done in your past yeah
you're gonna have to deal with because
there's dollar amounts here associated
with some decisions you've made in the
past but you know what
you are going to be able to create a
plan
and have the ability to walk through
that where those past decisions no
longer have to be the decisions you make
in the present or in your future
um but it's gonna be hard it's gonna be
a lot of work it's gonna be a lot of
discipline there's gonna be good days
there's many bad days it's gonna be a
it's gonna be a journey
um but we wanna walk you through that
and help you yeah one of the things that
i think
is going to help you um in this process
kirsten and it's not going to be
something that's going to flip a switch
overnight but we've got to get your
income up because you feel like you're
drowning not just because the debt is so
big but because the debt is big and the
income is low right now and so it feels
like you're trying to catch a tidal wave
with a teacup and you just can't and so
i want you to think about what are some
things that you can do temporarily in
this season maybe a year two year three
years like for the short term and maybe
it's something where you take another
part-time job maybe you you work your
way into a better job that pays more
maybe maybe it's a combination of these
things maybe you start a business on the
side i don't know what that looks like
for you but we've got to get a bigger
shovel to dig ourselves out of this mess
and that is going to give you a sense of
confidence it's going to reignite that
hope where you begin to chip away at it
quicker and that momentum is going to
actually fuel you making more progress
sticking with it
keeping you motivated and so on right
now it feels hopeless because the the
progress is so small um so i want you to
think about ways to do that one of the
things i would love to
give you and when you when we get off
the phone here if you'll stay on the
line i'll have jenna be sure to get this
to you let's give you a year
subscription to ramsey plus which is our
money class financial peace university
you watch these videos it's not just
going to get you fired up it's going to
show you step by step how you're going
to work your way through the baby steps
how you're going to list your debts
smallest to largest and dig yourself out
of this you can do it and this is going
to show you in depth
how to do it much more than rachel can i
i can even go into you know in our phone
call the other thing i'm going to have
jenna give you
is a live stream ticket to our business
boutique event it's this coming thursday
through saturday it's october 14th
through the 16th and even if you don't
want to start a business what's so
beautiful about this event kirsten is we
spend a lot of time just injecting hope
in people just talking about you can do
this
and you will do this and it's going to
help you push past your fear it may even
spark an idea of how you could earn some
extra income on the side
when your daughter is in school after
work hours when you know whatever that
looks like
you can get creative to find multiple
sources of income we don't have to feel
trapped
by this 17 25 an hour that's not our
only source of hope you are in control
of moving some levers and and pushing
things and getting creative and and
maybe a combination of these things
we're talking about so whenever we get
off the phone we'll make sure that jenna
gets you a year to ramsey plus to show
you the money steps and the money plan
and then also a live stream ticket to
the business boutique conference which
you can watch all next weekend anytime
that you can you can watch it later
we'll make sure you get set up where you
can watch it later if it's during your
work hours and that might just spark an
idea of how you could earn extra money
to pay this debt off faster i think
those two things will give you a sense
of control
reignite that hope that we're talking
about and show you step by step how you
can do it it was like what we were just
talking about rachel
the unknown is so scary i don't know how
i'm gonna do it when you begin to lay
out this plan
when you begin to lay out this path
kirsten and you see how you can do it
it's going to fire you up and give you
that sense of confidence and control
when you see it you know you can do it
maybe a long road and it may be a hard
road but you can do hard things kirsten
you're already doing hard things you're
tough
hard is not scary to you it's the
unknown
you're really really tough and you can
do this
and i just i want to give you one word
of encouragement
that i feel like i need to say uh my mom
was a single mom
and i remember her feeling really guilty
when i was growing up that she felt like
she was harming me by working hard long
hours taking me to her business back and
forth
and the thing that i tell people today
as a grown woman almost 40 years old
myself i say i just want you guys to
know i didn't make it despite the
struggle
i made it because of it
i am who i am because of my mother
and your child will be who she is
because of you because of how you fought
for her how you're a fighter and
survivor and you will not give up and
you will make a way and you are her hero
even if you don't feel like it right now
you're gonna get out of this
you are
you are you can work hard you already
are
we just need to give you the steps and
the plan to do it
and we're here for you so you call us
back anytime kirsten okay you call us
back anytime for help support resources
anything we can do
we're cheering you on yeah and on the
and on the tactical money side kirsten
that's what's gonna that ramsey plus
it's gonna help you create a budget
know exactly what bills are coming in
what cashflow you have from your
paychecks where everything's going there
will
i'm praying have a level of control
because
uh let me ask you this have you have you
ever lived just even on a on a monthly
budget i'll say do you have you have you
been consistent with knowing
where your money's going
i have not no yeah so then you know
where to start yep and that and that's
okay and that's okay and this again we
can't deep dive into it right now on
this call but but ramsay plus we'll walk
you through all of that and i'm telling
you kirsten those little just even
tactical things
it is gonna help bring such clarity such
clarity but like christy said kristin
you're a good mom
your your net worth is not your
self-worth this does not define who you
are as a as a as a woman as a person
your value is so so huge kirsten even
though life has
kicked you hard and and i can hear it
but but there's hope and you can do this
you're going to get through it and i
can't wait to hear from you when you do
you call us back and tell us your story
i want to thank producer james childs
associate producer jenna coletta my
co-host rachel cruz and you america this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm christy wright author of the
new book take back your time the
guilt-free guide to life balance and i
am joined today by my very good friend
fellow ramsay personality
rachel cruz we are hanging out answering
your calls so give us a call triple
eight eight two five
five two two five anybody that knows
rachel and i y'all know we love to talk
so we are here
to talk to you we'd love to hear your
story
answer your question give you some
advice uh that may help you make a
decision or just kind of like the last
call maybe just find some hope in an
area that you need it we all need that
from time to time so yes give us a call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five and we're going to
kick this off with
uh new york oh new york new york with
xavier let's see if i said that right
hey how are you
i'm doing very well thank you how are
you guys javier sorry javier how are you
i'm blessed to be our measure how are
you great great answer how can rachel
and i help today
okay so i'm 25 years old um i guess in
baby step 3 i have a little over 30 000
invested
um but
should i invest 13 000 into a career
that i have no passion for
but would help me
pursue my passion um i have so many
follow-up questions keep going what is
this career why does it need 13 000
okay so i graduated in business
management and i've gotten job offers
that pay well 70k 80k
but my passion is going to like because
i grew up in mexico i was born in the
u.s but i grew up in mexico and i like
going back
and and giving back to them because
there's a lot of people there that
are very underprivileged are very um
hungry and just
as bad
and so right now i actually work with
grubhub because it gives me the ability
to just come work as much as i can
and then go back and and pretty much
just give most of it away
and so i want to get into software
development i don't have a passion for
it
but i know it's something that i could
get
a remote job for where i could travel
and with that money be able to do what i
love which is just helping others
in these countries
well i love your heart i love your heart
to help people i love how you're
thinking you're very others centered
javier and i think that's an amazing
posture by the way that's not something
that can be taught
and that's going to serve you really
well in life whatever you do
i will tell you i i challenge the fact
that the only way that you can make good
money to be able to do what you want to
do is through software development i
think there's a lot of ways to make good
money
to be able to do what you want to do or
yeah i mean especially in our world now
i mean there are more remote jobs you
know
freelance contract based online based
than ever before what's your background
then
so in business management right okay
yeah beside uh
javier besides obviously um
giving to
the country you grew up in in a
financial way which i think is beautiful
and like christy said um absolutely
amazing
uh what else would you say that that you
love what what other things are you
passionate about i'm just trying to find
a way because the perfect because yes
could you go do software development
make 80 grand change people's lives in
mexico without 80 grand 1000 absolutely
but i think a bigger win would be to
make that 80 grand or more
doing something that you love and is
fulfilling and you're passionate about
in the creativity and the way you're
gifted all of that is coming together
to make a great income to do the same
thing so that that's the ultimate goal
um
and so my question would be is there
anything else besides yes you have a
degree in business and
all that but is there is there any other
career path or anything else that you
just love and you're passionate about
so
i think it's just i'm very people
oriented so i i hear ken sometimes ask
like oh if you could wake up tomorrow
and do whatever you want and not fail
it would just be something where i could
inspire people give them hope um where
they're like wow you know what i mean i
grew up with this atmosphere my whole
life thinking that this was my future
forever
but there isn't and you know there is a
whole oh there's a future out there for
me because um
you know that that's where i would be
like just and i don't know what position
that would be what job position that
would be hey let me tell you something
really cool javier
what you just described
is not software development
you are a people person
you are a people person you get your
energy from people rachel and i we're
speaking your language we are wired just
like
you don't hang out javier we'll hang out
you can do something you can do
something you don't need to do software
development you will die a little inside
every day i can see it let me just give
you an example as one possible avenue
for you just one this is not the one you
have to do but just to show you
you could absolutely
make 80 grand
as a business coach
inspiring people working with people i
have women in my coaching group the
academy that are business coaches that
are consultants that make well above 80
grand coaching small business people
one-on-one i coach them to coach their
people you could do that virtually you
could do it through zoom you could do it
through a subscription model you could
do it on the road you could do it
through courses you could have a youtube
show a podcast you could have a blog
there's so many ways
creative ways for you to do what you
want to do to use your gifts and talents
which you're going to be better in
business when you do what you're good at
and passionate about if you're not
passionate about something people will
feel it
and so i want you to brainstorm what you
could do that you're excited about that
you're excited about that can also make
good money and you know sheryl sandberg
said in her book lean in some of the
best career opportunities are not
positions that are posted but problems
that you solve
and that thing becomes your job
and so i think that you can figure out
what problem you solve for people who do
you want to help what people what people
group here from a business standpoint
from even a
freelance you know standpoint that you
want to serve or maybe there's a company
i'm not saying it does it can't be a
company you can make good money with a
company
in a business field you might start out
making less than 80. especially you know
when you're when you're right out of
school you'll probably start out less
than that work your way up there's a lot
of ways to go about it i just want to
challenge you that the only way to do
what you just described you want to do
is not doing something you hate
and in fact i think that's a bad
strategy to get there because you're
going to be miserable you're not going
to stick with it when it's hard because
you're miserable
the results are going to be poor because
you're miserable
and the people on the other end of your
work are going to sense that you're
miserable and so we just want to help
you figure out your strengths and stay
in them if you'll stay on the line i'm
just being very generous with ken
coleman's book today
i am i am santa claus with ken coleman's
book uh stay on the line javier we will
have jenna send you
uh get you the pre-order for ken
coleman's new book from paycheck to
purpose he also has an assessment that
goes along with it to help you identify
what your strengths what your passions
the results you want to get this is
literally what we're talking about with
you today you can take that assessment
now i believe when we get get you set up
there jenna will do that and then when
the book is available in november send
you a copy of that you follow that he'll
show you his path to figure out what
you're going to do but i guarantee you
what you're going to do what you're what
you should do
is something that you love something
you're passionate about something that
gets you excited so that
you can make the impact that you want to
make i can't wait to find out what that
is for you thanks for calling
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
i'm christy wright and joining me today
is my good friend rachel cruz and we are
taking your calls triple eight eight two
five
give us a call if you have a question
about money of course as always
business
how to have enough time
maybe just a big decision you're facing
and you want to run it by someone
sometimes it's good to have a
objective outside third party and we
would love to talk to you
and help you think through that triple
eight eight two five five two two five
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window covering you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promo
codes they run every month you'll save
even more
use promo code ramsey to get the best
deal rules and restrictions apply
so today's question comes from lindsay
in california my husband and i are in
baby step two with about eighteen
thousand dollars in debt i work in
elementary education in a high poverty
area so my students often go without i
can't help but buy extra shoes extra
snacks and classroom supplies for them
do i stop donating completely until
we're in a better place financially or
should i budget a small amount for
school each month
even though we are in debt i can't help
but see how much more we have and
there's so much guilt tied to that how
do i handle this i feel the weight of
the world on my shoulders
uh lindsay that's um
that is difficult because day in and day
out you're faced with a really
hard issue right poverty is a is a um
an issue that obviously is being tries
to be tackled from all different types
of directions with all different types
of thoughts and all of that so so what i
want you to say is that this is an issue
that's been
that has been forever even in biblical
times right there there are elements of
poverty so
i don't want you to have this um
savior mentality that
um
because you feel the way to the world
that you're you're not jesus like you're
not gonna be able just to take all the
pain away so i need you to to
feel that for a little bit
but also what i love so much
is that these students have you and
their lives because you obviously care
for them you obviously see the need
that might be very obvious some days
more so than others
and you want to fulfill that need and i
think that's an absolutely beautiful
thing and that's one
part of our financial plan that i
i love so much that we stand on that you
give something every month we recommend
ten percent
uh no matter where you are financially
and depending on if you're a person of
faith if you consider that the tithe or
something else you want to give to um
but that giving is going to be part of
your financial formula even on baby step
two even on baby step one so giving is
part of this so
a couple of things to consider number
one
yeah that you can continue to give
absolutely and maybe you and your
husband agree on maybe a certain dollar
amount or a percentage
uh every month consistently and if this
is where you're choosing to give
then that's great i think on the season
if this is it
do it
and then i would say you're gonna be in
a position though when you are out of
debt
and you have for you and your husband an
emergency fund in place kind of what we
always say that financial foundation
to give even more because that's what we
talk about around here is that you live
like no one else so later you can live
and give like no one else so the impact
that you can make when you don't have
payments and you don't have that
eighteen thousand dollars hanging over
your head that when your income comes in
it's not going out to debt payments it
is all yours you're gonna be able to
give so much more even then which is
just a beautiful thing so um so i don't
want you to feel like you have to be
jesus and that you're gonna save every
situation um i think that it can be easy
to get sucked in because you know these
kids you know their stories and it's
heartbreaking and
all of that but
you're you're not going to save them um
in in in a
in a sense of you know being being jesus
in that way uh but i think you have a
beautiful opportunity to help in a
really really impactful way and and i
think even more than just money like i
think the money portion obviously is a
tactical way to help that they are in
need of and of extra snacks and shoes
and all of that um but you being a
support system in a place that maybe
they have a lot of instability at home
that you can be that stable person
there's there's an emotional
spiritual gift that you can also give
them that i'm sure you are lindsay you
sound you sound like an incredible woman
yeah and the thing that i um that i
would just encourage you and rachel said
this but i just want to reiterate is
just come up with a number
come up with a number that you put in
your budget for that giving is it a
percentage of your income is it a dollar
amount and you just say hey we're going
to set aside this this piece of our
giving
for this specific cause and then what i
think that's going to help you do
lindsay is i think it's going to help
you set a goal around that a boundary
around it define success and i don't
mean that success like you're now jesus
but it just gives you something versus
always feeling like wow no matter what i
do it's not enough it doesn't make a
dent
instead you're going hey let you and
your spouse uh sit down and pray about
what is the number that you feel good
about hey every month we want to set
aside this amount of money for this
specific thing for the socks for the
snacks for the shoes for the supplies
and we're intentionally choosing to give
that and so on the months where it's
needed in the months where it's not you
get decide how you allocate that money
for this thing that you care deeply
about i think it's just going to put
some healthy boundaries around it where
it doesn't feel like oh my gosh no
matter what i do it's never enough
and but then you also get to exercise
that part of your heart where you want
to give so i i love that it's a it's a
great question and
yeah your students are lucky to have you
you sound wonderful all right we're
going to go to
where is this maine with ashley ashley
how are you
good how are you guys good what's going
on
good um
so i have been between baby step one and
two
for
a few years now and i'll admit sometimes
i lose my gazelle intensity
but i have a lot of like chronic medical
stuff and i have insurance but
sometimes like i just have extra bills
that i have to pay for it and
i guess i'm just looking for a little
encouragement or advice because i kind
of hold off on medical things to be able
to like get my thousand dollars in the
bank
and then i'm like oh shoot now i have to
do like go to the dentist or i can do
that and
then it's like i pull from that so then
that decrease again and then i build it
back up and then i have to like have
other appointments
and i just feel like i'm just constantly
stuck in between one and two and i i
like
get out of one for a little bit and i'm
in two and then i have to pull from one
again
and i'm not sure
what i'm doing what's your what's your
medical condition ashley
yeah so i have like chronic back pain
chronic neck pain
um i also have uh like lock jaw so
um i i clench my teeth at night so i
have a lot of dental
work that has been done and has to get
redone because i clench my jaw so tight
that it punctures the feelings and
i'm sorry so that's kind of an ongoing
thing yeah and
like i have
ptsd in my background and i've dealt
with just a lot of different health
struggles and anxiety and yeah all of
that so there's counseling yeah
there's a lot yeah yeah i'm sorry i'm
sorry that sounds um it does sound like
a lot and and um that's hard so i'm
sorry about that uh
where are you at just in the financial
aspect how much do you make a year what
debt do you have in baby step two kind
of give me a little bit give me some
numbers
yeah so i have about 7 000 in debt right
now which is my car and then a couple
credit cards
um and usually that's it seems like
that's just kind of where my debt
lingers is in the like six to ten
thousand
um that seems like it's just been
constant for the last few years um i
make around 24 000 a year
um
but i also miss a lot of work here and
there so like i'll budget like i try to
do the every dollar for the month and
i'm like okay this is my budget but i
i budget as if i'm not going to miss
work so then if i miss work what are you
doing like oh shoot i came up short what
do you do um right now i'm just a
delivery driver
um for an auto parts store okay
all right ashley a couple of things um i
want you to cut up the credit cards
right now
you're kind of being ramsey-ish is what
we would say you are
just kind of dabbling dabble and dabble
and dabble and dabble and dabble a
little bit you got it you got to go all
in ashley you got to go all in so you're
kind of the credit cards you're going to
you need to find another career you need
to find another job you can make more
than 24 000 i believe that i really
really do you need to be making more
income
and those two things are going gonna
help settle and make you truly get in
this more intense mode where you are all
in instead of kind of here and there
even though it's hard it's possible
ashley you can do this
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right we are back and we have got
brian and caitlin on our debt-free stage
in the lobby welcome guys hi hi thanks
so i'm guessing this means you are debt
free yes correct oh awesome well where
are you guys from photo springs colorado
springs and how much debt did you pay
off we paid off a hundred and
seventy-five thousand dollars wow
what was that of what did that consist
of uh student loans and cars okay
awesome and uh how much what's your
range of income during this time we
started at 97 000 and flexed up to 220
and then
and then came back down to 160. it was
it was a gazelle intense yeah it sounds
like it how long did it take you guys to
pay this 175 off 27 months 27 months
okay what bump the income up just extra
extra jobs did you do just kind of the
classic like hey we're gonna work
overtime there were several promotions
and then
yeah also additional jobs for sure yeah
at one point i had four i had four jobs
yes
what were you doing i was just curious
um so my day job is that i'm a facility
administrator and dietitian for a kidney
company okay and then i did online
dietitian work for telehealth and an
intensive care unit and then we also did
rover and then he had two jobs as well
3d printing on the side yeah wow
which one was the most lucrative brought
in the most income for you guys our day
jobs yeah yeah yeah well i'm sorry of
the side of the side side part-time jobs
um my intensive care unit job okay yeah
yeah man y'all hustled like you did not
sit around and wait for this to go away
you all got after it you are the epitome
of gazelle intense okay so tell us your
story you had 175 000 in debt student
loans car all that
27 months ago what happened what changed
so at his previous duty station we had
just bought our house and then i was
listening to the radio and heard some
guy yelling at me that if i can't afford
a car without cash then i need to ride a
bike
we have no idea who that is
yeah who is that
we were coming back from ikea with all
the furnishings in the back of the
minivan and i said hey listen to this
guy that i heard on the radio and the
story was kind of what we thought ours
was and then we got home and actually
laid out all the debt and i
printed off a thousand dollar increments
of all our debt and staple all together
and it was a chain that was like oh like
five feet long and it was so horrifying
and we're like okay let's do this wow
that visual is that something that like
really just it imprinted it in your mind
yeah it definitely did yeah so we hung
it up underneath our degrees and all of
our race photos and yeah we just were
like okay like we've done this we've got
degrees we've run marathons like let's
do this too yeah okay so kaitlyn you you
know you heard i need to ride a bike
okay we got to get this in order
okay what did you say then
as as this as the spouse brian were you
like go okay you're crazy or were you
like okay
maybe we would do it i mean from that
day i mean we were both just convicted
okay i mean just driving home we both
decided that you know this is when our
life changes wow that's awesome that you
guys were on the same page so quickly i
know it's a blessing for sure do you
guys have kids we do okay how many we
have two and how old are they six and
seven six and seven yeah and how were
they and part of this journey oh they
they wanted to help us with everything
they were so excited about it too and
then he deployed six months before the
end of the payoff
and that they would sit with me in the
office while i did my second job and
like bring dinner in there and we just
saw this together and at the very end we
had a huge celebration they did like
poppers and they they were all really
excited yeah okay so did you guys become
debt free when you were deployed uh soon
after yeah but that was definitely the
hardest part yeah for sure well thanks
for your service we actually took a call
from our military family in the first
hour about that he was getting deployed
and walking through
that yeah people does like you know even
when they're deployed people are still
chipping away their debt and you guys
are that here you are literally standing
on the stage oh absolutely incredible
what part what what service did you do
active duty air force okay yeah
wonderful thanks again
amazing for your support so
sorry can't jump in uh
so what was what was the hardest part i
mean i i would assume that deployment
was a big big hard part of that journey
but for you guys was it sacrifice of
lifestyle what was kind of the the rub
the hard hard part um i think when we
were both working seven hour weeks we
basically just like high five in the
kitchen and then yeah go to our other
jobs like um and then he left and i was
still working 70 hours and he was
working like 80 out being deployed and
it just just
the work honestly yeah what kept you
motivated through all that we were so
close to the end and just we i mean
there was times where he'd have to pick
me up off the floor and i'd be like i'm
so tired i don't want to anymore but
then like i'd do the same for him it's
just it's nice when one of us was down
and the other person get help yeah yeah
just cheering each other on thankfully
nobody got down at the same time
you can take turns
picking each other up who were your
biggest cheerleaders other than you guys
um i mean most of everybody thought we
were crazy honestly um but our friend
heather she was getting out of debt at
the same time and actually ended up a
month before we did and so we had a big
celebration together oh wow and then my
previous boss rachel she helped me take
on the second job so that i could get
out of it too because she did that
before us as well so amazing so so you
were in the car and you listened to this
guy yelling at you about the bike in the
car what how did you actually get on the
plan was it ramsay plus did you read the
book how did you work the plan or find
the plan i just listened to the baby
steps in the car you know just the show
oh yeah yeah listen to the show and and
that was it and that's amazing halfway
through we took financial peace after we
were like okay we kind of get this but
we kind of just want to get the whole
program and yeah see how it goes well
there's such value in the show of just
that regular motivation every day but
then in the class or the book to have
the plan all succinct concise step by
step you know it's good to have both
that's awesome
all right what is the um what is the key
everybody's listening right now that is
in baby step two they're like i don't
know if i can do it what for you guys
was the absolute secret to getting out
of debt the key that that made it work
i'd say just keeping your eye on the
prize i mean the the amount of
dedication was just extreme but you know
just having that vision you know being
financially free that's it yeah and then
also scheduling
ice cream dates because yes there's a
point he's the nerd for sure and he's
like no we can't do anything dave says
you can't go to a restaurant i was like
can i go get ice cream with the kids
so at the end of the month we would do
that that's good have a little the
little wins you gotta have the little
celebrations throughout for sure
especially with a mountain of 175
thousand dollars what i love about this
i mean obviously your income was insane
because you worked insane right i mean
you were working four jobs at one point
and so
the beautiful thing about this is i'm
like the sacrifice was so intense
but it was for 27 months and it was
probably the 27 longest months of your
entire life
but you look over the scope of your life
and you think oh two years two years and
it changes completely my entire future
financially of where we're at and
ultimately your entire life because
money is a tool to to help create a life
that we love and now the income that you
guys have it's yours
it's all yours and that sacrifice is in
the rear view mirror i know when you
were in it it probably felt like it was
going to last forever
but now it's behind you and you don't
have a payment in the world how does it
feel how does it feel to be standing
there completely debt-free so good free
yes
yeah yeah now you can now you can have
all the ice cream you want to come on
all the all the celebrations you guys
want to well y'all are amazing well done
you guys worked so hard you did not sit
around you are the definition of gazelle
intense got that income up and uh just
uh just heroes y'all are amazing we have
a copy of the legacy journey for you
guys because that's definitely the next
stage in your story we have a copy of
the total money makeover you can give
that to a gift give it to one of those
people that thinks you're crazy maybe
maybe you will bring them into the crazy
and help them start their debt-free
journey uh but y'all are awesome okay
y'all brian and caitlin from colorado
springs colorado paid off
175 thousand dollars
in 27 months making a range of 97 to 220
000
count it down let's hear a debt free
screen
three two one
yes
yes yes yes oh i i just i love their
story because even with that
mountain of debt 175 000 which would
feel
like you're never going to climb out of
it yeah they just got that much more
intense yes they took on that many more
jobs they got their income up more than
double
and we're able to get out of it and i
just hope for any of you all listening
right now that have a huge amount of
debt and you're feeling like i can't
tackle this
you can it's what you were just saying
to that caller before you can you can
make changes you can increase your
income you can make different choices
that lead to a different result yes it's
a short-term sacrifice but it's also
worth it oh so worth anything about
those kids yes six and seven year old
i'm like and their entire life is
different because their parents chose
chose to do something and not just sit
there and just accept it that's right i
truly you guys were proactive and and
you changed your lives it's absolutely
incredible it's an honor honor to talk
to them yes yes this is why we tell you
guys to get gazelle intense it takes
that dave ramsey says you can wander
into debt you cannot wander out you've
got to get intense if you're going to
change this thing but you can do it this
is the ramsay show
so
[Music]
[Music]
i'm christy wright joining me today is
my good friend rachel cruz and we are
taking your calls triple eight eight two
five
five two two five and we're gonna go to
philadelphia pennsylvania with becky hey
becky how are you
hi i'm very good how are you good what's
going on
so my question is how do you create a
budget after betrayal i just found out
six weeks ago that my husband has been
cheating on me
um he is repentant and is we are both
seeing counselors and
trying to work through this and last
night we tried to do our budget we have
been following the ramsey plan for a few
years
um
we are completely debt-free including
our house
so the thing we're not on an agreement
on is do we stop our investing
and dip into our emergency fund
or do we
keep investing and use the money that we
sold that we made from selling the
business
yeah we we got a lot going on here becky
what business and what money do we need
to dip into for anything because i
thought y'all were debt free help us
understand what specifically you're
talking about
um my husband sold his business dude
yeah and they got a new job
because yeah he would have more
accountability there and he would not be
working by himself so we sold our
personal business so the money that we
need from that we could use to help pay
for counseling and also we took a pay
cut so
to
help us through the next few months
or years i guess it takes three to five
years to be
clean from all this okay okay well first
of all i just want us to say i'm really
sorry that happened i'm really sorry you
went through that and that's really
really emotional
to take on
in addition with trying to deal with the
tactical so um yeah you know rachel i
will definitely help you process the
tactical of the money um but i i'm just
so um so glad you guys are in counseling
because that that is just gonna be so
great to have a professional in your
corner to help you process that
as you're going through that yeah and
becky you know we
will say a lot on um
on this show that when something
kind of tragic happens um just to pause
that you're good you know just
take a deep breath and um you know a lot
of times when there's grief involved and
there's a love and there will be grief
with this um situation when you're six
weeks out it's still really new
uh
yeah this wasn't six months ago or six
years ago i mean this this just came out
last month right so um yeah so i would
say you know you guys are you're in
on the financial side you're in good
shape right you you guys don't have debt
yeah you've taken a pay cut your
lifestyle make a little different but i
would i wouldn't make any
i know you guys sold the business to get
him in a position with accountability
and all of that and i think that's a
smart move on just you guys and how
you're going to function going forward
um but i wouldn't do anything rash i
wouldn't make any big decisions right
now because there still is a lot of pain
and so i think for you all
just um the budget's probably going to
look different
because of the pay cut and so i think re
re-looking at
not trying to keep the same lifestyle
and so
when you asked about stop investing and
all of that i would do what i can to
to
and again it's going to be hard because
it's going to look different your
lifestyle will look different
um and try to
live within that new income is going to
be um the best thing going forward
versus
taking money out of an emergency fund or
stopping investing um to keep the same
lifestyle that you guys were living six
months ago it's just you're in a
different you're in a different spot so
i would do what i can
to
live off of that new income
that he has create a budget around that
and even if you guys can't for some
reason
make bills on that but you should be
able what what is it becky i don't know
if she said that what what is the income
the new income
the new income
um
i'm trying to think
anywhere from
the 80
around 80
50 to 80 something like that
so it's
his first he just got his first paycheck
it was 2200 for two weeks so whatever
that would be annually
okay honey something
funny i didn't do the math but yeah so
if you're debt free i'm just curious
i'm not great at you know mental math on
the spot but if you're completely debt
free
why do you feel like that you couldn't
live on that that you'd have to dip into
savings or stop retiring stop your um
investing for that
why wouldn't you be able to live on that
is it your house um
no
the one thing so
because we had inconsistent income
before we try to do our budget a month
before so like what he gets from october
we'll use for the november
um budget so he's working ahead
and
yeah the thing is we had we tried to do
a month budget off of a two week
paycheck and i was like okay we need to
move money over and he was not okay with
that he's more like he like to pinch his
pennies and
okay no i'm we don't need to we have you
know so much saved up in our retirements
or in our business account but we don't
have to pinch our pennies right now
he's been very controlling
which
makes me angry
yeah what
i hear that in your voice becky
is that something you're working through
with your counselor because that that's
a strong word
i said that can be
um
yeah
it just came up so
um
i haven't been
i've been trying to but
but it's painful
do you ever do you ever talk to your
counselor just you
without him present
yes i do okay
are you honest with your counselor about
what's going on yes yeah
i guess this financial thing never came
up before because this was our first
budget meeting
so yeah yeah and
well i was just really triggered i guess
you could say yeah for sure
for sure um do you think as of now and
it's six weeks after i know um that you
found out but are you got you're you're
working to stay together and you think
that that do you see hope in that yeah
yeah we we both want that okay um okay
and i am seeing a change in him so yeah
he wants to change okay so that's one
thing i'm like i even thought about like
creating the budget myself instead of
because of his
bad decisions he made
like he was spending money on unreported
side jobs so yeah i mean like using cash
in that way for
yeah i was like i can't trust him with
the finances right now so that would be
my thing like yeah which is legitimate
becky yeah yeah that's that's legitimate
um
yep when there's um deceit and lying
uh that's where that goes so
um and do you work outside the home i i
do not i'm a stay-at-home mom right now
okay
um
okay let me just again let me answer a
tactical question for you just so when
we get off the phone you have something
um to think about so when you're saying
that you're you guys have never budgeted
before just know that it's it is always
tough okay so you guys running into
these kind of conversations and all that
affair or not is very normal so just
hear that give yourself a lot of grace
so the first few months of this is going
to be difficult
um
and number two the the two-week paycheck
is difficult too to budget because what
you're saying is the money that happened
from the last paycheck is what you're
using for this and all that so so in an
ideal world and especially since you
guys are debt free to have enough money
in the checking account that can help
you pay for a month's worth of bills
on a tactical level is going to help so
if you need to pull that month from your
emergency fund to have to be able to
physically pay the bills and then as the
paycheck comes in for the 15th you're
going to use that 15th and then the 30th
paycheck for the next month does that
make sense
yes you're going to still budget every
dollar but the actual cash flow can go
so for him pinching the pennies and all
that you guys just need money in your
checking account
to help get this budget flowing so you
can do that
um i i'm all for that
and and for you guys again yeah getting
a budget together i think is is for sure
in a perfect world but no you there's a
lot of pain becky so i just want you to
have a lot of grace for yourself and if
you guys can't get to this
for another two or three or four months
like
it's okay
your marriage is important right now and
yes money is a big component of that and
i want that to get together but i want
you guys to heal from your marriage
which is going to help heal
from the trust with the money as well
and bring that up with your counselor
bring the budget conversations as an
example of the conflict or control to
your counselor and help them work
through that and dig to the deeper
issues they're they're great at that
that's what they do
thanks for calling i hope that
encourages you and helps you get through
this tough time i want to thank
producers james child associate producer
jenna coletta my co-host rachel cruz and
you america this is the ramsay show
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker just
tell alexa google assistant or siri to
play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsay show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life and your money i'm christy
wright and joining me today is my good
friend fellow ramsay personality rachel
cruz and we are taking your calls and
answering your questions we love talking
to you we love hearing your stories
and you all know we love giving advice
so if you've got a question about money
and you're not sure what to do next how
to work the baby steps what about a
specific situation with your money
rachel is here i'll jump in of course if
you have a question about how to have
more time reach your goals
start a side business or small business
or maybe grow your business really
whatever you want to talk about we're
here for you triple eight eight two five
five two two five and we are going to
kick this off with rachel in milwaukee
hey rachel how are you
good how are you guys john good what's
going on
so um my husband and i have kind of been
wrestling with a decision um we've been
married for about two years now and are
starting to think about
the timing of when we want to start a
family um so i know this decision you
know is going to have a big impact on
our lives and i'm the nerd and i want to
consider all of the factors that kind of
go into that so um i know you two are
you know proud mamas and i was just
hoping you might be able to shed a
little light on how we might go about
this
that's so great wow i have my knee jerk
answer
i know what it is go on go on i mean
rachel start a family when you want to
start a family
i don't think you have to be in a
certain place financially i mean
obviously yeah if you guys have stable
careers and no doubt i mean there's
obviously financial
life situations that will make it less
stressful but i don't think that any of
those need to stop you from
from having a baby i think these life
decisions whether it's getting married
starting a family it needs to come from
you guys and when you guys are ready
so that's my that's my we can we can dig
into it more but that's not just well i
can't answer and because rachel because
you're the nerd admittedly you said it
not me because you're the nerd you're
rachel you're not this rachel i'm a free
spirit no you take the nerd rachel
you're you're talking to two free
spirits here so like ah it's great go
ahead do the thing but for you i'm sure
it feels intimidating like oh it's going
to add so much money and the reality is
a baby
as wonderful as this is is something
that you when you have a baby you just
begin to put line items in the budget
for those babies that baby's needs and
so whether it's diapers or whatever that
just becomes a new line item that is
either increased from like household
expenses however you name it or a new
line item that is not there currently
and you just begin to plan for that so
for you is there something specific
about your financial situation that you
feel like is kind of a hang up for you
or is it just the unknown of of how much
that's going to cost of actually having
a child
yeah i think it's actually not so much
the financial part we don't have any
debts
but we have recently gone through some
career transitions my husband and i and
i am working on wrapping up an online
master's program um in the spring so
it's just kind of
you know do we
you know go ahead and just go with it or
do we kind of you know
plan it very strategically
what do you want what do you want to do
do you want to finish your master's and
all of that and start a family in 12
months do you want to start next month
what do you when do you want to have a
baby
i can't decide i some days i'm like okay
she's like that's what i call it
um i mean i mean honestly rachel it it
really is i don't want to be a broken
record on this call but i mean it really
is when you and your husband are like
okay and let me say this too you're
never gonna actually feel like oh we're
for sure ready that's a fact like
there's always gonna be something oh we
didn't travel to this place or we didn't
make this amount of money or we didn't
we need that i mean there's always going
to be something out there now
is there a common sense factor of this
that maybe you want to finish your
masters before you know you have a sure
that's great you've been working a
master's plan and if you're like yeah
the timeline i'd rather get that done
and out of my you know
um
get that out of the way and all i mean i
don't know it's gonna really have to be
um something that you guys uh to the
point that you're like we're ready well
and the other piece of this which i
think is just everyone listening to this
understands intuitively but is important
to say out loud is you can't fully
control it that's right so you've got to
be ready
whenever you guys are ready in case it
comes easy for you and you've also got
to understand that it may not and take
six months a year
longer and so there is an element of
this of yes you can plan as much as you
want to plan as the nerd as the the
planner the masters consider all the
things and still know there's a piece of
this that you're holding without open
hands and trusting and um and knowing
that you're going to control what you
can and and trust with what you can't
control so i know that this is probably
not the answer you wanted rachel but it
is such a personal decision and if
anything i hope we just encouraged you
that it's not a financial decision it's
a personal decision and it's something
you pray about if you're a person of
faith you talk to your spouse about and
you guys
make the best decision you can with the
information that you have but i love
what rachel said that it's absolutely oh
so true you're never fully ready there's
never this moment's like yes i'm ready i
totally know what to expect i have got
it
that probably doesn't come so you just
make the best decision with the
information that you have
all right gonna go to josh in spokane
washington hey josh how are you
hey i'm doing fine um
so my question is so i'm saving up i'm
still in debt with my mortgage about 130
000
and uh so i stayed up i actually have
about 110 right now
um
it's all in one bank account and so my
wife's telling me you know based there's
some bank uh
there's probably not the best decision
to have it all in one uh spot i wanted
this to ask you that
um
for like a investment purpose or for a
safety purpose like what what makes you
think not
it's really just there you know once
once the money's there to pay off the
mortgage um and and to do that
basically her rationale is too much
too much cash to have in one bank uh
bank account do you would you have any
suggestions on how to uh to spread that
out a little bit so i just want to i
just want to recap something and clarify
something so you have 140 000 that you
owe on your mortgage and you have a
hundred and ten thousand
130 but yeah and and i have about 110 uh
state does pay off that mortgage okay
what have you all been waiting on
in terms of putting that large amount of
money that you have on the mortgage why
are you waiting to do it all at one time
well just um so we refinanced here about
a year and a half ago
and then just not
i guess just to have a little bit of a
safety net not to put all of that on the
mortgage at one time because we continue
to uh to make mortgage payments right
well not all of it but like i don't know
70 80. like just to put a big chunk on
it to bring down
your balance your interest everything
while you're in the process i mean you
guys are so close to the finish line
it's irrelevant now but i was just
curious if there's a reason to wait to
do it all at once
well there was some discussion at one
point as far as selling the house here
recently and uh so that that never
transpired
um but either either way the money's
still there um
it's go ahead well i was going to say
make sure that you have an emergency
fund you guys need like six months set
aside out of that 110 if you don't
already and that's kind of your cushion
that's your safety net and then throw
everything else yeah at the mortgage you
got cash there yeah put it at the
principal and it's in a savings account
because it's accessible it doesn't need
to be spread anywhere else because we
just need to access it in order to make
that payment when you're ready to um so
savings is fine for you don't invest it
yep yeah thanks for calling great job
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at zip recruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com ken sign up today
absolutely free and let zip recruiter
work for you
[Music]
so
[Music]
well we've heard all the excuses people
use to put off making a will you're busy
it's confusing it's expensive it's
morbid and makes you uncomfortable well
our ramsay solutions research team found
that 74 of parents
don't have a will guys
this is too important you need a will to
protect your family even if it's
uncomfortable for you to do it stop
putting it off and get it done start
with our free will preparation checklist
this guide helps you think through seven
important areas like naming guardians
and beneficiaries plus all the little
things you haven't thought of maybe
didn't want to think of that's all right
you still need to think about it
once you've gone over the checklist you
can actually get it taken care of in
about 10 or 15 minutes with our ramsey
trusted online will provider that's all
it takes 10 or 15 minutes y'all you can
do this
get the guide by texting will to 33789
that's will to 33789
give your family peace of mind by
getting yourself a will and i'll add
if you haven't updated your will since a
major life change or just in a really
long time revisit it this is a great
gift to your family and just for your
own peace of mind so that's will to
33789 text will will
23789
i'm kristy wright author of the new book
take back your time the guilt-free guide
to life balance that just launched a
couple weeks ago
how's it going how does it feel it
doesn't feel like it's out in the world
it's so fun to hear the feedback yes
because you know this anytime you put
something out there in the world you're
like i hope they like it
you know like it's
our editing team makes it you know
better and fixes all the grammar and
punctuation but you don't know until
it's in someone's hands
and it has done so well it actually hit
the bestseller list two weeks in a row
which is huge and then you're hearing
this feedback of people going i've never
heard of life balance talked about this
way this didn't just give me my time
back it gave my power back and so it's
been really fun to hear it's actually
helping people which by the way
is exactly why we do
what we do we want to help you whether
it's with your money or your time or
your career or anything we just want to
help you guys we want to give you the
inspiration to help you believe you can
do it and change your life because you
can
and we want to give you the instruction
the step-by-step
plan that will show you how to do it
that's what we are about here at ramsey
solutions as ramsay personalities
regardless of our message regardless of
the topic that's what we want to help
you do we want you have the information
and the inspiration
to help you change your life because by
the way you can we're taking your calls
for a little bit longer eight eight two
five five two two five if you want to
call in for rachel or myself
we are here for you all right we're
gonna go to rebecca in la hey rebecca
how are you
hi i am good thank you sir what's going
on
so i'm struggling with a career choice i
had made and now i'm not sure what to do
next i felt led to
leadership i work in healthcare
i'm a nurse
and we talked i talked a lot about this
with my boss my husband before i did it
and so when the opportunity came i took
a nursing leadership position in my
organization and it's been so hard
through the pandemic
um and now i don't know if what i'm
experiencing is healthy striving and
growing pains
with this
new position or if i am overworked and
just stressed out and can't handle
if this is not the right fit for me so
that's my first question and then also i
already know i can't stay where i'm at
but i don't know if i should find
leadership in a new
way or if i should go back to
you know bedside
caregiving yeah well in relation to the
first part of your question that is hard
to discern that it's hard to discern do
i not like it because it's different and
not for me or do i not like it because
this is the season we're in health care
we're in a pandemic and i'm embracing
leadership like oh rebecca right it is
so
hard i don't know how much of that you
can tease out and the other piece of it
is um there are things that are specific
to the pandemic but i would say that
they're in any industry but especially
healthcare there are things that are
specific to the pandemic but that won't
go back to normal there are things that
have become
new rhythms that that will be forever
changed because of the pandemic so i i
think that is really hard to tease out
the first question that came to mind as
we dig into this with you
is do you miss
regular nursing do you miss bedside do
you miss being with patients
as you think about this as you think
about leadership versus
bedside care do you miss the the regular
nursing aspect of your job
yeah i do
um um i think that'll always be my first
love no matter what i decide
yeah
let me let's go back to when you decided
to take this leadership role and there's
no wrong answer here i just want to get
to the root of it some people take
leadership positions
because it feels like the next logical
step because they feel like they're
supposed to because they feel like
they're supposed to want it because
there's more pay possibly involved when
you think about why you took that what
was the real motivator for for taking
that new role
yeah yeah it definitely didn't have
anything to do with pay um leadership
suited me um a lot in
my um young you know
young adulthood and everything and
family here as well and something that
my boss and i started talking
um about you know years before it came
up as an opportunity and even me and my
husband talked about it quite a bit
i just i love people
i love um i love precepting so i l you
know i love teaching and i love
um
you know helping other people learn and
to be the best nurse that they can be
and
at the same time around the same time
when i had decided to do this there was
a um one of our pastors
began um
talking about um leadership as
servanthood and i thought that's what i
want to do i want to you know
um so anyways it you know it felt like
the right thing to do for a lot of
different reasons
the things that you just described do
you get to do that in your current role
so that's the i think that's
what i'm struggling with is a lot of
what i do right now is very task
oriented and i know they're important
but i feel like i'm not
doing the things that i thought i would
be doing in leadership and i don't know
if it's just me
like i said teasing out what
you know expectations versus reality or
um
or if this is just not a good fit for me
and you said already that you don't want
to stay where you are like you're
already committed to looking for
something somewhere else right
yeah yeah i think you know i think that
this last experience
pandemic aside this last experience has
taught you
a lot about yourself of what you love i
love how you were able to articulate to
rachel and i
i love people i love teaching these are
the things that make me light up and
come alive this is what i'm good at this
is what i get excited about so when you
move because it sounds like you've
already decided to move companies move
you know hospitals or wherever you're
going to practice this i think you begin
to really look for those specific things
because you know that now you know that
every leadership title does not involve
what you thought it did and you can
begin to look for that yeah and
sometimes rebecca not always and this
may not be the case for you but we do
find when you are
really good at a skill right so a nurse
for you
or someone is a writer a really great
writer or you know you can fill it in
and when you're really good at it
obviously other people notice that and
they think oh you're really good
you should automatically go into
leadership and again sometimes that is
the right move and the things you
described i think there are leadership
positions i would hope that had that you
can do those things and still be a
leader because all that but sometimes as
well it kind of goes like no but i just
i love to be a nurse or i just love to
write i want to go back to writing i
don't want to go back to managing people
over a writing department at a company
or something you know so
so i think that um
asking yourself those questions too
which i think you were at the beginning
of the call but just to kind of figure
out okay would i rather just go back to
what i love
being a nurse
and doing that job just really well or
is there a leadership position where you
still get that fulfillment of your skill
that you're really good at
with in addition to helping people learn
taking other people to the next level
and all of that yeah i think when you
begin this search rebecca because it
sounds like you're already on it um
maybe just add to your tool about some
questions when you're interviewing and
say what is the typical day look like
for this position yeah what are the
typical day-to-day activities and really
get to not just the job posting what
they say it is but what really goes on
what's the day-to-day operations the
day-to-day activities and then you'll
get a hopefully a more accurate picture
of if that's in line with what you love
and if it's not and that's just going to
help you
sift through this next move that you're
you're committed to make even if it
takes a little bit more time to find the
right thing but i think you can do it i
think you will thanks for calling
rebecca
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 a month to get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract the average family
saves over seventy dollars a month by
switching to pure top just go to
feartalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
[Music]
christy wright joining me today is my
good friend rachel cruz and we are
taking your calls about anything and
everything triple eight eight two five
five two two five and we're going to go
to rebecca in honolulu hawaii rebecca
how's the weather in hawaii
[Music]
oh it's beautiful rachel christie thanks
for taking my call need to come and
visit you there what's going on how can
we help
sure i have a question about um the zero
credit score so my husband and i are in
davis steps four five and six we are
both dual access dual active duty
military i am looking to retire in one
year
and he's about
two and a half years he'll retire as
well
and we're gonna look to buy a house at
that time so with our credit we did have
a home um in virginia before coming to
honolulu and we sold that recently and
so our credit score was always good
because of the mortgage right but with
that off
it's obviously dropping but i have one
credit card left open on my account our
bank requires a line of credit to do
mobile deposits and so i have that open
so that i can do that hasn't been used
in years
but if we're looking to buy a home and
to
by two and a half three years
we
either need to have a credit score that
will get us a loan or have a zero credit
score so that we can get manually
underwritten and i'm not sure how long
it takes to get to that zero so
i mean at this point i believe we could
cancel that credit card we're in a you
know strong enough financial situation
that the mobile depositing while it's
convenient isn't a necessity yeah
but i'm not sure how long
that process takes i don't want to put
us in a situation where we go to buy a
home and our scores only fall until like
400. yeah no no it's a great question
no for sure well it will never go to and
it's not really it doesn't even really
go to zero goes to what's called
undetermined is what it is so okay it
will go to undetermined when you have
all accounts closed
and all debt is paid everything
correct for six i mean again
six to 12 months is kind of the estimate
but with fico we don't know their
algorithm specifically but that's kind
of on average of what we're seeing is
six to 12 months but you keeping that
credit card open that is an open account
so it will never fall to undetermined so
you have to get rid of that so whether
it's switching banks or like you said
you can take on um that for the the
mobile deposit all of it whatever it is
you got to get rid of that and so after
that is closed then it should take
another six to 12 months to fall to
undetermined
okay
that was my concern is the amount of
time i got close it and then we're ready
to buy and it took years first you know
right right and again that that's on
average but i'll say with the asterisk
that again fico
we don't we don't have their specific
formula their specific algorithm and
everything on when that starts to fall
and when that actually does become
undetermined but on average
that is what we're seeing but it's a
great question because every people are
listening
who are getting out of debt that's one
reason we do say you don't need to buy a
house
when you have debts and part of that is
because as you're paying off your debt
what you've experienced is that your
credit score starts to go down because
everything mathematically that creates
your credit scores every for everything
from the new type of debt you have um
the the types of debts to um there's
about seven categories there that
calculate your credit score and when you
don't interact with debt
it starts to go down so that's a it's a
great question and one that we get a lot
but i would close that credit card
account get it undetermined then you
guys can manually underwrite that
mortgage in two to three years yeah and
it sounds like uh with the time frame
that you're on you're talking about this
even for next year being as soon as
sounds like that will will still work
for you and great job on being debt free
so yeah well done yeah and thanks for
your service all right sheena's in
charlotte north carolina hey sheena how
are you
hey ladies i'm doing great how are you
great what's gina we've talked before
haven't we
yes we have and i i you were on my show
the rachel cruz show you were a guest on
on one of the ask rachel episode so i'm
so glad to talk to you again oh i'm
excited yeah what's going on i'm so
excited to talk to you too well um as
you know i drive a lot for work and i
typically stop at you know gas stations
along the the interstate and because
i've covered and everything i've been
trying not to use cash and go in
physically to
the gas station so instead i've been you
know use my visa debit card out of the
pumps but it's been
scanned now probably three or four times
in the last year
so i'm you know facing um
charges that i didn't do and things like
that and so it it's
you know the companies have been great
and they say well okay yes they came out
of your cash but we've closed that and
we're you know we'll refund you but i'm
just my biggest question is what's the
safest way to buy
cash during these covert times you know
i i used to use the cash and go into the
store but again with the delta variant
and everything i'm trying to limit my
exposure i guess being six months
pregnant yeah um
so just trying to figure out what's the
safest way to buy gas yeah and well i
would say i mean my my answer is still a
debit card that's the only way i've
bought gas for probably 10 years i
probably have not walked into a gas
station with an actual envelope of cash
even when we do the envelope system we
tell people hey there may be categories
that you don't cash out for convenience
purposes like gas right when you're at
the pump you can just do your debit card
so i'm so interested that it got that i
mean it does it i mean there are tracker
you know there is fraud and gas stations
is a place that gets hit a lot but i'm
surprised it's been so often are you
using the same
company like the same gas
brand yeah so i've said it so that's the
thing is that i've switched it up
because thinking same thing okay well if
that gas station's been compromised well
then i'll try a different one yeah um
and so i even wrote down you know with
with my husband who actually does fraud
for for a living as a detective and we
kind of went through and said okay well
it can't be the costco's because we
always stop there and um that's kind of
new within the last little bit
so it's got to be you know this one or
this one but these ones are new within
the last two months but we're just
trying to kind of figure out okay where
not to stop but again i have to stop
so yeah it's just amazing what the
safest way to do this is
but the same program that that when they
do fraud would take a credit card as
well now so even if you're doing a
credit card i mean it's the same thing
now
when you have a debit card you still
have the same protection so the fees and
stuff
should not you shouldn't have to be
paying those that should be protected by
whatever companies there on your on your
debit card whether it's visa or
mastercard yeah
so the only fees that they've been
charging me is to expedite the new card
in the mail oh okay okay i hear you
right here and it's just a headache
it's just inconvenient this is annoying
you know that you that it keeps
happening i'm so sorry that's so that's
so weird is it all in um when you say
you drive a lot is it all in charlotte
or do you drive out of town
i drive out of town a lot you know all
over north and south carolina and it
happens anywhere you go it's not like
just a particular city
right
right commonly between charlotte and
charleston south carolina is what i've
been noticing hmm
i don't know i hate to say i don't
really know what to tell you yeah i've
been doing i've been doing debit card at
a gas pump for 10 years and and i've one
time one time it happens yeah so it's
happened to me one one time too sheena i
think it's super odd it's probably i
mean part of it i'm sure is just the
frequency with which you are traveling
getting gas so naturally you're going to
fill up more than someone else does so
the chances of it happening are greater
i mean if you want to wear a mask or a
couple masks and go inside if that would
give you peace of mind to not worry
about it getting skimmed um you can do
that but i i don't i don't think there
are any variables at play
that are in your control you know what
i'm saying like you don't you don't you
can't look at the pump and know if it's
going to happen and you can't control
the creeps that are out there doing it
and you've got to get gas and so
all you can do is control what you can
which is either put on a mask and go
inside
and pay cash or
just deal with the crap when it happens
which i hate that's happening so
frequently to you because
you've got to be on the phone and press
one press five press zero wait for a
representative oh it happened again you
know so it is annoying it takes so much
time that's so frustrating so i'm so
sorry that happened uh yeah i don't
think there's anything
outside of what you're doing that you
could do more of um but um but you know
hopefully hopefully they get on top of
it and it's something that just stops
because they get they catch the people
and it stops happening so sorry so sorry
that's happening it's one of those
things that's like there's just stuff in
life that we can plan and plan and plan
and crap just happens i know
there's still going to be something
you're going to get a flat tire
someone's going to skim your debit card
you know something's going to go wrong
so inconvenience of it all hate that
hate that for you sheena but um
hopefully it'll stop happening soon and
you can just get on the road and not
have to worry about it that's right
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
philippians 4 13 i can do all things
through christ who strengthens me
zig ziglar said fear has two meanings
forget everything and run
or
face everything and rise the choice is
yours i love that there's such a theme
in our call today just injecting hope in
people that feel
hopeless and i love those reminders from
the scripture philippians 4 13 and the
quote from zig ziglar well the last 18
months have been a lot
you know it i know it a lot of worry a
lot of wondering what would happen next
maybe that's how you feel about your
money too
tired stuck
stretch thin
but it doesn't have to be that way
you just need a plan we've been talking
about this all day today because a plan
gives you confidence even when
everything else seems out of control
and that plan is financial peace
university this class will teach you
everything you need to know to save
money
pay off debt and build wealth for the
future you can stream the lessons on
your own or get support by going through
the class with others
then you'll put that plan into practice
with the premium version of our every
dollar budgeting app by syncing your
bank to your budget you can easily track
your spending and see where your money
goes you get all this only with a ramsay
plus membership
you don't have to stay exhausted and
overwhelmed you can
win with money
to start your free trial of ramsay plus
text trial to 33789
that's trial two three three
seven eight nine rachel cruz and i are
taking your calls triple eight eight two
five
five two two five and we're gonna go to
kansas city with lacey hey hey lacey how
are you
fantastic thanks so much i'm so glad
it's you two ladies today perfect for my
question i love it let's have it
okay
so i have i am a mom of three small
children
i have been in and out of college
changing my mind for what seems like
well almost 10 years now
i think i finally settled on what i want
to do like a dream but
you know i don't know if it's to quote
you
right right now
there you go
you know i
want to be home with my kids
and
anything i can do with this
sort of starting my own business
would keep me away from them a lot and i
you know and
the degrees i'm chasing aren't extremely
relevant to what i want to do and
schools
that have the degree i want are in other
states and i just
i'm tired of
working you know like waitressing jobs
when
i need you know to support my family i
need to
you know
grow the family tree
change the legacy etc
yeah yeah well um i i've got a few
follow-up questions as rachel and i dig
into this are you married
yes okay and what's your household
income
uh
around 40 000. okay
so
when you said you finally settled on
your dream job i think is the way that
you said it or your dream path what is
that
um
anthology you know i want to study
animal behavior maybe be
you know a more tame version would be
like a pet psychologist and the more
wild version would be you know the
people that are on national geographic
and follow the cheetahs around and
why did they do that kind of deal yeah
yeah
well one of the things um
lacey i'll just i'll start with this and
i think that this has um relevance to
what you're saying one of the things
that i think um feels very overwhelming
to people not just women but
specifically in your shoes of being a
mom of three littles
is when we try to do everything at once
and in the same breath you said i have
my dream to you know
chase tigers on national geographic also
i want to be with my kids pretty much 24
7. so like
two of these things don't go together so
i mean chasing kids is kind of like
chasing tigers in the wild
but i think we might need to choose the
seasonality of your dreams and
it's not that you can't you know just i
mean literally to quote my book just
because something's not right right now
doesn't mean it's never right doesn't
mean you can never do that but i think
it does come down to prioritizing what's
right right now what is what is a one
right now because you're gonna feel the
most sense of peace
when you do what's right right now and
if that's being there for your kids and
and being super involved in their lives
being there for field trips being there
for that kind of stuff and and to your
point either taking a part-time
from home job that's pretty flexible or
starting your business from home where
you get to set your hours to make that
number one priority of being there for
your kids possible or if it looks a
different way i think that you're going
to feel the most contentment and purpose
and peace when you do the thing that's
most important and then maybe pursue
that in another season now if you want
to pursue that now because you're saying
this is most important you can do that
i'm not saying what's right or wrong i
just want to echo what you said to me
about the kids because that plays into
the timing of some of these career
decisions how yeah how old are your kids
lacey
uh five two and seven months old
you're in the trenches with us too we're
all tired let's just talk about it you
were in the trenches
girl i feel you you have no idea
you have no idea
yeah so i mean i yeah i think it i think
what christy said though is spot on it's
a question that you can only ask
yourself or answer yourself
is what what do you want to do do you
want to be home with the kids
more and more and that's an okay answer
you know i mean 40 grand it's like yeah
maybe you can find something on the side
a little bit to bring in some extra cash
if you guys want to depending on where
you are in the baby steps and your needs
and your wants all of it um
or yeah is there a thing out there that
you're like no it's it's going to take
time to get whether it's the education
or to get qualified
and then actually doing the job that's
going to be time away
from the kids that's just we only we
only have we can only be in one place at
once right um
so it's that's gonna have to be a
an answer that you that you come up with
when i want yourself i wonder if there's
a piece of it too i love helping people
come up with a um almost like an interim
solution so sometimes when we think of
our dream we think of this big like you
know the cadillac version of our idea
i'm like is there a is there a baby
version of our idea like a starter
version of our idea where sure you're
not chasing tigers on national
geographic but maybe you start a side
gig
uh pet sitting or dog walking or just
something to engage your love of animals
which i know i i i understand walking a
dog is not the same as chasing a tiger i
get that but i'm just saying it could
create income you could set your hours
and it could engage that part of you
that loves animals in a creative way
that's one way to do it there's multiple
ways for you to do it i just want to
challenge you to think of what could
that look like in this season how could
you engage your love of animals of the
wild of you know nature whatever
in this season in a way that brings in
extra income for your family if that's
what you want to do and
and still allows you to be present in
this season so i think just like rachel
said i think it's a question only you
can answer um but if you'll stay on the
line i will have jenna send you um a
live stream ticket to our business
boutique event you can join us next week
it's october 14th through the 16th
it's here in nashville but we're live
streaming the whole thing and what you
can do is you can tune in and watch
those sessions it may help you think of
a business idea may just encourage you
in this season of helping you discern
what's right for you and um and you can
watch that and hopefully hopefully that
will help maybe bring some clarity to
that but it really is a question only
you can answer and rachel one of the
things that's interesting about some of
the calls that we get some of the calls
we get on the show is black
or black and white yes you should do
this no you should do not do that that
is a bad idea this is a good idea and so
on some of them like a couple we've had
today are more values calls they're more
um what do you want to do
what's right for you and no one can tell
you and i think we i think we really get
ourselves in trouble
when um maybe we listen to someone
else's advice someone said hey you have
to go back to school or you have to
pursue this degree or you have to
live your life this way and it's not
right for us and so even well-meaning
people can maybe steer you in the wrong
direction and so that's why we want to
turn it back on you yeah
with your husband as well you guys talk
about it and because there's also i
think a benefit especially with a spouse
because they know you better than anyone
he can call out the things that he sees
in you hey i do see you light up in x y
and z or hey i feel like you i feel the
stress the tension more and more when
when x y and z happens like like have
have him be a sounding board as well in
this process and he can really help you
navigate i think spouses there's a gift
in that yes um as well to come up with
the best decision yes chris and your
whole family so fun that's so fun with
you today i love it oh my gosh her
little her little kids are out there you
can't see them cause we're on the we're
on a podcast they're running around
ready for mom of the weekend it's
awesome it's fun friday all right we
want to thank producer james child
associate producer jenna coletta my
co-host rachel cruz and you america for
tuning in this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com
and register we would love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story
[Music]
you